[موسيقى]
رسم اكثر عن هوايه بالنسبه لي
بديتها من صغري وطورتها مع الايام بديتها
برسم الطبيعه
والجمادات ومع الايام تطورت لين 2011
تقريبا بديت في رسم البورتريه انا اختصت
في حاليا
[موسيقى]
الشيء اللي يجذبني اكثر شيء في الملامح
تفاصيلها اكثر
[موسيقى]
شيوخنا اللي هم تفاصيل معينه من تجاعيد من
رسمه العين هالاشياء تجذبني في الصوره
نفسها الصوره اللي انا اختارها عشان
ارسمها
ادمج بين نوعين من الرسم اللي هو بالرصاص
ارت وهذا الشيء يعطي حياه للرسم اكثر
نقطه تحول بالنسبه لي رسمه الشيخ سلطان
القاسمي رسمتها في السوشل ميديا ولقت
اعجاب للكثيرين حتى في صفحتها الخاصه تم
عرضها وهالشيء يشجعني وخلاني استمر وحصلت
دعم كبير من شيوخنا
وناس مهمين في السوشيال ميديا وهذا الشيء
وصلني للمكان اللي انا فيه حاليا وان شاء
الله اوصل مراكز اكثر واحسن
طموحي حاليا اني اقابلهم شخصيا واحد واحد
وارسم الشيوخ ربي يحفظهم قدامهم واوصل
رساله لبلادي في نفس الوقت
الرسام هو اللي يختار عناوين لوحاتها وانا
كرسامه اخترت شيوخ الامارات لان الشيوخ
الامارات يرمزون العديد من الاشياء عندكم
الشجاعه الكرامه الحب الوفاء الاخلاص كل
لوحه تقدرون تشوفون صفه من صفات شيوخنا
[موسيقى]
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات